NATO soldiers are being put through
their paces in Poland they're taking
part in operation noble jump the series
of exercises that test the group's Rapid
Response tubes the force has been set up
to counter possible threats in Eastern
Europe following Russia's annexation of
Crimea but German security experts say
the move could raise tensions if Iran
had orchids I'll pass has shown us that
every military measure nature takes
provokes a reaction from Russia whether
it's maneuvers or an increase in defense
spending that creates a threat of an
arms race the consequences of which are
possible to predict songs kiala and his
vet was since med look which wound up
Steve on phone the experts warn that the
West shouldn't send forces to Ukraine to
fight against pro-russian separatists in
addition to imposing sanctions they
should focus on building a lasting
security framework the report says the
West should also exercise restraint in
Iraq and Syria weapons deliveries to
Kurdish troops are not the right way
forward they say yeah thanking the
sassoon we believes that a general
rethink is needed towards a more
preventive foreign policy and we believe
that the use of military measures should
be limited to situations where there are
humanitarian emergencies the group of
researchers would like to see greater
Democratic efforts rather than maneuvers
like those underway in Poland